as always our recordings of our virtual
meetups will be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we'll
post a message on the meetup when the
recording is ready
next i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today
eduardo blancas-reyes eduardo is
interested in developing tools to
deliver reliable data products towards
that end he created
plumer hopefully he'll correct me on
that pronunciation if it's not right
i'm in
an open source python library to compose
production ready data workflows eduardo
holds an ms in data science from
columbia university where he took part
in computational neuroscience research
eduardo started his data science career
in 2015 at the center for data science
in public policy at the university of
chicago
today our speaker is taking questions
throughout the talk so feel free to put
them in the chat um and i'll ask i'll
interrupt and ask as they come in
we'll also have some time for q a at the
end
eduardo take it
away thanks uh thanks rebecca for the
introduction and thanks to everyone who
is here to watch my presentation i
really appreciate that you take the time
okay let me start by sharing my screen
okay um so i'm gonna show a few slides i
don't want to take too much time showing
slides uh the the interesting part the
the phone part is gonna be the the demo
for the tool that i'm going to be
presenting
um but i want to show a few a few things
about the tool that i'm developing so we
kind of have some context and background
of why i started working on this project
um so
my name is laura blancas and i've been
working on this project called bloomberg
and the name of this present the name of
the presentation is developing
maintainable data pipelines with jupiter
and bloomberg
before we start with the slides i want
to show a few things so first this
project is open source
you can find the project on github
please if you like the project support
us with the star on github
only takes a few seconds and it helps us
reach more people
help more people discover the project
and they can start using it and benefit
from it
also if you decide to use plumber we
also have a select workspace you can
find the link
here so we have that space for people to
ask questions
um request features and chat with other
people who like jupiter like um
building pipelines so it's a very nice
place to
reach out to the community and
just to to chat if you wanna say hi uh
you can find me there
uh finally we published um a few weeks
ago uh guest blog post on the official
jupiter blog so if you want to um have a
summary of what i'm going to present
today you have it here so just go to
blog jupiter.org
and then it's going to be one of the
latest entries in the blog so you can
find the
the summary here
okay um that's it for the introduction
now um let's give some some context for
this this project um why i started
working on this uh
some some of the things that i've seen
recurrently when people work with
jupiter is that they
open a notebook and then they start
coding an internal analysis like
everything from
getting some data cleaning some data um
if they are doing machine learning they
train a model they evaluate the model
they make predictions everything um
in a single file
now that creates a lot of issues first
thing is if you have all your analysis
in a single file it's kind of hard to
understand what's going on
there aren't clear boundaries between
the code that loads some data the code
that cleans the data
um
and also if you're using git which is
highly recommended for any kind of
programming project
it's hard to use
and follow best practices practices
that
software developers use for example
doing pull requests or
all the the workflow that software
engineers use to build
their projects
and just to give an example of these
kinds of things if you
push um
a jupyter notebook to github and then
you make a small change
and you take a look at the difference
between the initial file and the file
with the changes you're going to see
something like this and this is a
notebook that i changed and the only
thing i did was to add a new sale
so new sale with us a comment
and you you cannot understand this thing
right it's kind of hard to understand
what's going on
um and for for developing software it's
really important to do version control
and be able to
take a look at the previous version
compared with the new version
um
to have this um in an organized way so
there
this is one of the first issues that you
encounter when you try to work with
jupiter notebooks
now a second problem is that if if you
cannot um
build or if you don't work on something
that many people can work on at the same
time uh it becomes really complex to
collaborate like many times before i
started this project i would uh work
with some someone and maybe we could do
some we can we start doing some analysis
i have a notebook that other person has
a notebook and then at some point we
have to collaborate maybe i have to use
the output from
their analysis as an input to my
analysis so i just request some data and
tell this person hey can you send me
this this data i needed to do some
cleaning or to create some charts or to
train a model
and that person may say okay i'm gonna
send that to you
um
[Music]
and then i start using that that file
the problem is that if
we don't know
um where this data came from we have a
huge problem of reproducibility
if we don't know how we got from the raw
data to this new clean data set or
transform data set
it's really hard to make sure that we
are able to reproduce our results and it
just makes collaborations so difficult
because we are just exchanging
files um and modified files
um and we don't really have a way of
saying
this is the raw data and then we apply
this in these
transformations and then we get to this
final result that's another big
important problem
now let's talk about the solution and
the solution that i'm going to talk
about is how how we think
about a solution for all of these
problems and and how we apply that to a
framework which is bloomberg that allows
you to solve these issues of
collaboration of using
notebooks
but also using it and avoid these
um these problems so the first thing is
we change the the underlying format
uh the the classic format for um
jupyter notebooks is the ipi and b form
and as i mentioned before it has
has some issues so first thing we do is
we use um a library we rely on a
third-party library called jupytext
which allows you allows us to support
different formats and then
operate them as notebooks so if you take
a look at the left
image you're going to see that i have a
dot pi file and i'm opening it in in
jupyter
and i can open the same file in in vs
code and it's just a python script it's
just like plain python script
and i'm not going to encounter any of
the issues
that i would have with the other format
so
you can also use ipi and b files with
with plumber
but using dot py files makes it much
simpler to manage so that's the first
thing using scripts as notebooks and i'm
going to show the in the demo this is
going to become
clear now next thing
i also i mentioned that sometimes or
most of the time we start a notebook and
then we code an inter analysis on it and
it just becomes really hard to manage it
and especially if we are doing some
large project we have more than one
person working on it or more than one
data set it becomes
really hard to manage
what plumber allows us is to break down
that analysis into multiple small parts
in a really simple way so it almost
feels like we are working on a on a
single notebook except we are dealing
with multiple files
now the benefit is that we can um
specify clear boundaries in in our
analysis we may say
we are going to use the first file to
load um some data set
now then we are going to have a second
file to load another data set and these
two files never interact with each other
because they shouldn't they are dealing
with different things
different data sets uh and we apply the
same reasoning for other operations that
we uh
we
other things that we do to the data so
we may clean it
uh clean the data and we have a script
for cleaning text a cleaning dataset b
and this is a sample machine learning
pipelines so let's say we generate some
some features
uh same thing so these are completely
independent until the final step which
is training a model
and then at that point we merge
everything that we have done before and
then we train a model right but
previously all this remains independent
which means someone may go inside this
uh file and modify it
and i might be working on a different
file and we are not gonna get into each
other's ways because we are working on
different files and there are like clear
clear boundaries and also clear
responsibilities right if we are saying
this file is going to clean data set a
then we expect the output of this to be
a clean data set
so we can kind of set those kinds of
expectations about what each part of the
analysis is supposed to do now
as a consequence of having this
modularized code we get also other
benefits and this is also another
feature that i'm going to show
which are incremental wheels
let's say that we are working on this
pipeline and i train a model right so
i've run everything and then this this
script trains the model
now i find some issue in one of the
features so i fix it in fitters
underscore a i fix that problem and
change the code and now i run everything
again
since i didn't modify most of my
pipeline it's wasteful to run everything
from scratch so what plumber allows us
is to just run the things that have
changed
so in this case if i modify features a
it's only going to run features a and
then train the model again
what this allows us is to experiment
much faster which is really important
when we are working with data
if we clean that if we start cleaning
some data we are not going to get it
right on the first attempt right we are
going to find some find some other
issues
so really working with data is an
iterative process like we do something
and then we find some issue we go back
apply some new transformations and
repeat that um so plumbing allows us to
iterate much faster because we don't
have to repeat redundant computations
um
another important thing is testing so
this is something that
doesn't happen often in data science
and i think we should test more because
it helps us
build more robust
projects so just to give an example i i
mentioned before that if we modularize
our work we have clear boundaries and
clear responsibilities about each part
of our analysis so if we say that some
script
or some notebook
cleans uh some data
we can test that like if we have a
definition of what clean data means for
some specific use case might be we
shouldn't have um values for this column
outside the 0 to 100 range for example
we can define those rules and then
plumber allows us to embed tests data
quality tests so we make sure that every
time we run this script we test the
output and if it doesn't
um fulfill our expectations in terms of
data quality then we can stop execution
and say hey you should take a look at
this because there's something going on
here
so making sure we have we are putting
high quality data into our pipeline is
really important and if we are able to
automate this process that saves us a
lot of time otherwise if we don't test
the the quality of our data we are going
to make a lot of mistakes and those
mistakes can be
really expensive if we for example
realize that we are training a model and
we deploy a model to production
with low quality data
and finally
what this allows us like all these
things that i've explained before allows
us to have a robust solution for
reproducibility and collaboration like
someone can start working on jupiter
someone may prefer vs code and and they
can both collaborate in the same project
in the same same pipeline
modifying
um things at the same time sharing
things on on github and and
streamlining this process
okay so that's it for the explanation
now let's go to the to the interesting
part which is the demo
um
so here i'm gonna i'm gonna be running
everything on on jupiter but just so you
know you can also use any other text
editor um
but i know a lot of people like jupiter
and i like jupiter a lot so i'm going to
be focusing on the jupiter integration
so let's let's imagine we are
we are about to start uh and and also um
i'm gonna be making some small stops in
in each of the parts of the explanation
so um if someone has a question
you can just ask it and and also feel
free to interrupt me if anything isn't
clear
um and i can answer your questions
okay so now let's say we are going to be
starting a new project so first thing is
we executed this command plumber
scaffold and i'm going to be passing
this argument empty
by default bloomberg creates a sample
pipeline and in this case we want to
start from scratch so i'm going to
execute that
i'm going to call this empty
so this is going to create a new folder
you can see the new folder here
and for now let's only focus on the
pipeline jammel file the other files are
optional
let's focus here
this is the central uh file in plumber
it's a pipeline jml file where we
specify
each of the tasks in our pipeline so
that would be
each of these boxes
one script per box
and now let's say we are going to work
in a really simple pipeline
we are going to have three tasks one
that's going to load some data
for
okay
let's just
fix the indentation okay so let's say we
uh we are going to work on a really
simple pipeline only three tasks and the
first thing is uh we want to load some
data so i'm gonna say
first thing i have to specify is what is
the source code that i want to use
so let's say i want to load and i don't
have the scripts right now i'm going to
ask lumber to create the the basic
structure for me
so i'm going to say uh go to the scripts
folder and use the get.pi file now
what's going to be the output of that
script
um this is going to have two outputs
so first one is going to be a notebook
now this might be surprising right why
do we have
a source code that's a dot by file and
then an output that's a jupyter notebook
uh the reason is that bloomberg uses
executes plumber executes uh
dot pi files as notebooks and this could
also be a jupyter notebook but it always
creates a copy of the input file the
reason is that we may have some tables
or some charts in our source code that
we may want to take a look at later
so when we run the pipeline we're going
to run the script and then have an
output jupyter notebook
and then we can take a look at the
charts and we can also change the format
for example you can do something like
pdf or html
so what's going to happen is plumber is
going to take this run it as a notebook
and then
change the format so that's the idea
let's keep it as a notebook
now if this script generates some
loads some raw data we also want that to
be an output
so let's create another output so we
just say data and let's say products and
then raw csv
so what we have done so far is we
specify the first task
this is the input script
and these are the outputs
uh we just repeat the same operation for
all the other tasks
so let's say the second one is going to
clean some data so let's do clean let's
also change their name here
and this might be plain.csv
right and finally let's say we want to
plot the data
so this script
is only going to generate the
jupyter notebook as an output
but doesn't need to generate any data so
we remove that
and we just
have this here so this is the basic
structure of our project and now i'm
going to ask plumber to
create the basic files for me so i move
to the empty
folder that has my pipeline jammu file
and now i execute bloomberg scaffold
again
this time since i already have a
pipeline jumble file it's gonna create
those files for me so it's saying adding
scripts get scripts clean and scripts
plot
so now uh
here i'm going to show this um thing
that i explained in the slides about
using scripts as notebooks
so if i double click on this
git dot pi you're going to see that it's
just a
dot pi file with a few extra things
uh the details aren't important so i'm
just going to close this and here's
where the magic happens if i do right
click
open with notebook
let me see what happened
oh okay i see what happened
um so i have repeated files yeah so i
should name
my files in a different way so this
should be plot.ipinb okay
now let's do that again open with
notebook
all right so we have a dot pi script
that looks like a notebook and we can
interact with it as as a notebook
and we can do the same thing with the
other two files now let me show you how
the pipeline looks like
so i'm going to run kimber plot
to show you that plumage recognizes this
as a pipeline
so we now have we have this pipeline.png
file
we see these three
tasks
it looks a bit strange right because it
doesn't have any structure so that's
what we are going to do now
we say that we are going to get some
data but then we are going to clean it
and then we are going to generate some
charts so this should go first this
should go second
and finally we should plot some data so
that's what we are going to do how do we
do that
all right let's go to the
clean.pi file then open it as a notebook
now
this uh variable called upstream has a
special meaning because this is where we
specify
which tasks
should come before this one so if this
uh clean.pinestrip is loading some data
let's use the what's the name of get.pi
okay so i'm gonna do
upstream equals a list of a single
element the element is called get
that means execute get before you
execute clean now let's do the same
thing with plot
so same thing a list with a single
element in this case is going to be
clean so clean the data before you
create the plot
now let's go and create bloomberg plot
execute bloomer plot again and see
how it looks like now
all right now this makes more sense we
get some data
we clean the data and we plot the data
okay
um one important thing is
uh imagine that you are working that you
already have the code that gets the data
and now you are going to be working on
cleaning the data
if you are going to be using the raw
data as an input it would make sense for
you to have that information right where
is my get.pi script saving
the output
well
here we have all the information that we
need so what we do is once we modify the
upstream variable that specifies the
order
we can do file
and then
reload and you're going to see that we
have this
new information
so we we didn't code this cell this cell
is automatically injected by plumber and
it has all the information that we need
to start coding our analysis the first
part is you told me you are going to be
using
the get.pi script as an input so here's
the output of that script and we have
the path to the csv file and and then we
can load it
and the second thing is uh in the
pipeline jammu file we say that uh we
are going to be creating an output csv
file so we also have that information
here
and then we can simply use these
variables to load the data clean it and
then save it so this
uh prevents this allows us to have a
clean code that doesn't have any hard
coded paths and if we modify anything
here
then we're gonna see the changes here so
that's that's the basic idea like right
now in in just a few minutes i explain
how the
uh basic workflow looks like you have
some pipeline general files you specify
uh how many files how many tasks you
have then you go and modify the files
and specify the dependencies
and then you fill the gaps which would
be
the actual coding uh cleaning data
creating some charts
so now let me
show a different example because this
doesn't have anything this this uh
pipeline
doesn't have anything any kind of data
or isn't doing anything interesting so
what i have now is another pipeline
um also a basic pipeline that has some
code some um simple really simple
machine learning pipeline that gets some
data generated some features and trains
now the idea is that you see how it
would look like how the experience would
look like once you have
a first pass of your analysis
so same thing we have a pipeline jumbo
file but this time we have a mix of
functions
these are functions
and scripts and you can
mix functions with scripts or functions
with notebooks
uh whatever is easier for you and
whatever you feel the most comfortable
with
let me show you how the
cloth looks like for
this pipeline and then we are going to
um dive into the details of of this so
let me
show you this okay so
uh this is a really simple
pipeline we get some data
then i'm using the iris data set so i'm
sure you have used this data set before
for for some
tutorials or examples we get some data
we generate some filters
one one here one here
then we
join everything into a single file a
single data frame
and then we train a model so
it was really easy for me to explain to
you
the pipeline because we have this
graphical representation and this is
really useful when you are working with
someone else and i use this for for all
my projects at work
and
if i have to onboard someone else to a
project i
simply show this and
we can go back and forth with questions
so i explain i provide a high level
level explanation of
what the pipeline is doing and then
um
we can we can just have this like quick
conversation about what what's inside so
it becomes kind of a white box instead
of having all the details inside the
notebook and not being able to explain
what's um what am i doing i'm able to
do this kind of
explanation so now
um let's run this let's see how this
looks like in practice so how how would
i run this pipeline i simply have to do
tumblr build
and now i'm going to orchestrate
execution which means i'm going to get
the data generate the features
and then train a model
that's what's happening here
you'll see it's building the features
and then it's going to execute the
script that trains them all and that's
it so uh to
show you how this output notebook looks
like
let's go to scripts.um scriptsfeed.pi
which is the script that
trains a model
uh really simple
the details aren't important i'm just
training a model and then
printing a report with some metrics so
this is my source code this is the file
that i modify
uh and that i can make changes to
but when i orchestrate my pipeline i
have an output notebook which can help
me which is like a report right in this
case it's a model report model
evaluation report but this can be
anything
so we go to products
report
here
here
and you see this is the executed version
of my dot pi file and you can see my
metrics here
and if i had any other
plot i could i would be able to see that
here as well
and now let's let's show you the
incremental builds feature so let's
imagine we already have a first model
uh and we
want to create a new feature for example
so we go to
features actually no let's modify the
defeat.pi
file
let's go to scripts
open as a notebook and say
you know what i i want to
make some modifications to my training
code because um
you know just to for the sake of an
example i'm just gonna do one plus one
in in a real scenario this could be
maybe adding a chart
uh or changing some of the settings for
your model
and we modify the fit.pi file let's see
what happens if we run plumb rebuild
again
let's
remember how this pipeline looks like so
i only modified fit
i kept
all the other scripts uh sorry functions
the same
so let's see what happens
we are gonna see the incremental
build incremental builds feature in
action so you can see here that i only
executed well plumber only executed
the fit.pi script and it skipped the
other tasks because
it doesn't have to i didn't change
anything so what's the point of running
this again
um
and that's it there are there are many
other things so this this gives you um
a quick
overview of how the experience looks
like from
starting from scratch and then building
a step by step a pipeline and once you
have your pipeline working how can you
iterate on your pipeline you may
modify some of your existing tasks and
re-run your pipeline you may want to add
some new tasks
um
[Music]
and and that's how how the workflow
looks like now there are many things
that i skip to keep the presentation uh
short but i can briefly mention some of
the important things that um
that you can do so i mentioned in the
slides that you can um test
the pipeline so we could do something
like
let's say we want to test the quality of
our training set we could do something
we do
an unfinished section and then do tests
dot test my data set
and then
we create a test start by file create a
test my data set function and then we
can um
create some testing code there and every
time plumber runs this
uh function or a script can be a
scripted script as well it's gonna run
that function
so it makes sure sure that every time
you run a task you are testing it
and then we have we have some other
things
we can also run these things in the
cloud so if you
are working with big data and your
laptop or the server that you are using
isn't enough
you can export this pipeline and run it
in the in the cloud
and you can run it in aws batch
in kubernetes using our workflows and
airflow so that's another important
feature that you may be working locally
and then at some point you may want to
scale your analysis and you don't have
to modify anything like if it's a
notebook you can
run the notebook at scale if it's a
function you can run it in
in kubernetes without changing anything
in your code except adding a few extra
configurations
uh so that's it if you
want to know more please
you can join the community you can ask
me questions
uh and we also have um documentation
you can find the link to the
documentation in the github repo
and you can find lots of tutorials
to learn
many things some of the things that i
didn't explain here
so that's it i think we we can
open the room for four questions now
great thank you so much eduardo we
already have one question in the chat
from arielle this is great eduardo can
tasks be executed in parallel
uh yes that's a great question all you
have to do is
uh
executor
parallel
that's it so uh that that depends on the
structure of your pipeline
uh
in this case we have a few these two
tasks are independent so you can um
plumber is going to run them in parallel
and if you run this in the cloud
uh each task runs in a in a separate um
container so it also that's also going
to be executed in parallel um so i see a
second question how is this different
from um lyra uh that's a great question
i also i i talked recently a few months
ago to the um elite latest team uh great
guys
um
i think there are a lot of uh
things in common certainly especially
because
both of them are um
have this notion of building
uh pipelines from jupiter so i would say
like from from
the surface they are really similar
but the details are different i think
a lighter layers team is putting a lot
of work into
the different ways
uh for orchestration so you can run
things in i think cargo workflows as
well and some other platforms that we
don't support currently
uh whereas bloomberg is
i would say
we are putting more effort in
like streamlining the local experience
like we are we want people to be able to
run um
set up things quickly
and then start running things
uh
i i wouldn't say our priorities to
support
like many many platforms in the cloud at
least not right now that that's uh
that's one difference is one of the
differences
um
what else another thing is that we also
support
functions i am not sure if elida
supports functions as tasks and sql
scripts so
um i didn't show that but we we could
have a
a script a sql script as a task
um
and i i have an entry on on the on
bloomberg's blog actually i think that's
important to mention
uh if you go to the git homes repo then
click here
you're gonna find a survey i did here
and then i compare plumber to many other
tools
so you can see the differences
between them
great uh i have a question
um it's clear to me that this is a
really useful tool to use during eda
um as a data scientist and you're saying
you can also
run plumer in the cloud
so
um
you know like a typical data science
workflow
you know you'll do eda and then like
feature cleaning
and then model building and then
deployment maybe you'll iterate on these
things but is there a specific part of
this workflow that you think
plumer is better for or is it meant to
be like
um
the whole data science workflow you can
you can use it
that's a good point i think um
many many of the many projects that
work with data are really similar
because you are building something like
this right some kind of
pipeline and has certain order order of
execution so as long as you can specify
your workflow
in something like this
uh it works now
we are
working and we have some specialized
features for machine learning um and i
didn't mention this but for example when
you are doing some machine learning you
may want to train multiple models at the
same time and the only difference
between one model uh or one script and
the and the other is that maybe the
first one is training a random forest
and second one is training uh a neural
network
and we have some features that allow you
to quickly create an array or a grid of
tasks without having to
declare one task and then the other and
then the other so you specify the the
script that you want to use and then all
the uh parameters and then you can
quickly create a like a larger
pipeline
um but apart from that i could say
anything that you can specify as a
pipeline as an as a
as a
set of tasks that have certain order uh
you can use it because plumber is
agnostic to what's inside the script as
long as you have inputs and outputs
what happens inside this the script is
is up to you can be cleaning data or
feature engineering or creating some
report for example
great thanks
any other questions feel free to put
them in the chat or
um i think anybody can also unmute
themselves
rail says this has been great good job
thank you yeah feel free to reach out to
me um join the community or reach out to
me on twitter if you have
questions and hopefully you can give it
a try and use it for your next project
well that's really interesting
um i'm just curious is this something
that is promo born out of your hobby
are you full-time on this
uh it's it started as a pet project
actually uh
two years ago it was i was just
dedicating
a few hours
every week to build this and i decided
to open source it
and then people started using it which i
think was was very nice
and
for the last six months i would say
i started i started putting more effort
into building a community because we
have uh
companies using this in production
already which is um i mean when i when
they when they talked to me and they
told me we are using this in production
we have a few questions
um i was like i was like really really
excited and
now i'm trying to build the community
and help the teams that are using it and
the users are are building things like
really really different things people
are using it for research uh people in
industry
for deploying machine learning models so
it's growing and that that's exciting
wow yeah
truly amazing
yeah and i think it's one of the reasons
is that
there aren't many tools that allow you
to build
production-ready pipelines in jupiter
and i think that should change uh and
many times when i speak to
uh teams
from different companies they tell me
you shouldn't use notebooks in
production because it's a complete mess
and i know it's a complete mess but that
doesn't mean it has to be that way and i
really like jupiter and i feel like it
allows me to quickly build things
uh like explore my data create fit or
strain models
and what plumber gives you is that extra
ability
to move from your prototype to
production without having to
rework everything from scratch which
many teams did before they started using
plumber they could go and create some
notebooks and then once they had a model
or a prototype they would completely
refactor
and
turn their notebook into python modules
and then take it to production the
problem is that the moment you start
breaking things down and refactoring
uh it's really hard to build the same
thing again so they may not be able to
reproduce results um the model may not
have the same performance so
it's really risky to to do these these
these
things like refactoring everything just
because you don't want to use um jupiter
right so a lot of people
start with notebooks instead of python
scripts and with promo does that mean
that you always have to
maybe convert your notebook as the input
python file first
um
so that the pipeline would run or can
the input be directly not just jupyter
notebooks that's a great question you
can so let me uh so here right i have a
python script i may change this to a pi
and b and it works the same uh the
reason why we recommend using dot pi
files is because it makes it easier to
work with git but if you prefer the ipi
nb format uh you can do that and then at
some point you can if you want you can
convert the ipi and b to dot pi so it
allows you to to make that decision um
and then convert from one format to the
other if you if you have some reason to
do it uh but
you can have the pipeline
um
be composed or of of ipi and v files
it's fine yeah that's great and you
imagine that it could be sql script
as input
maybe in the future it could be
other
other programming language
yeah uh so right now we also support r
so this could be
instead of dot pi could be dot r
that works as well
um
then for sql i can actually show an
example uh really quick so we have a
project repo and have lots of examples
here
uh i think this one is the simplest one
so this one is a sql pipeline
that uh let me go to the pipeline
jumping for me
okay this has a little bit extra
configuration but let's ignore the first
part for now uh it's not important
uh so you can see here that i have some
sql scripts uh so i'm getting filtering
some table then grouping the table
so this is sales and this is prices
and then i join everything and then i
dump
the table into a csv file here
and then i use a dot pi file to generate
a chart so instead of having a single
file that
manages the connection to the database
and then apply some sql queries and then
downloading the data uh bloomberg allows
me to write sql scripts so i can show uh
how this looks like
so a sql script with some extra
placeholders
um
that we need to um execute the pipeline
but it's it's it's simple sql
and then uh in the pipeline general file
we have a task that dumps the output
of the the table in a csv file and then
we load that csv file into
jupyter so we only write sql files and
dot pi files and not worry about
uh managing connections to the database
and
we can we get all the other benefits
like running things in parallel
yeah so suppose you
you you want to run something is there
like a way to specify the
the software that um
right um
in this configuration file
uh for the database
doesn't have to be database maybe you
know i also use uh you know
matlab or other
software somewhere in the pipeline
uh
no fortunately we only support python on
r for now so this has to be sql a sql
file a python file an r file or a
notebook in python or r
got it okay yeah
really nice
any other questions
great well thank you so much eduardo
this is we don't get a lot of demos
actually so this has been really nice
great um thanks everyone for for being
here and
if you have any other questions please
reach out to me and i can help you get
started
my friends again life demos are very
challenging
you have done it perfectly
thank you thanks rebecca
yes you're a perfect host as well
okay
bye
bye everyone
bye
you